The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, so I've
got Quiz 2 to give back to
with good scores.
So it's Christmas early.
Or, good work on that exam.
That's fine and so we all
know Fourier series is
like a central topic on the
final third of the course,
and I'll just keep
going on Fourier series.
I'll give you homework
on 4.1 and 4.2.
So 4.1 is what we complete
today, the Fourier series.
4.2 is the discrete
Fourier series.
So those are two
major, major topics
for this part of the course.
This is the periodic one and
4.2 will be the finite one,
with the Fourier
matrix showing up.
OK, so can I pick
out, I've made a list
of topics last time that
were important for 4.1,
for Fourier series.
And I think these are the
remaining entries on the list.
I did the Fourier series for the
odd square wave, the minus one
stepping up to plus one.
And you remember that, well just
let me put that example down
here.
That was the step
function; easier
if I draw it than if I
try to write equations,
so it was minus
one up to plus one,
ending at-- of
course period 2pi.
And I guess we called that S(x),
for S signaling step function,
S signaling square wave.
And S the general a signal
that the function is odd.
And that means that it
goes with sine functions.
And I think the numbers that
we found from the formula was
sin(x)/1, sin(3x)/3, sin(5x)/5,
it's just a great one
to remember.
And that's the example
that has the important,
and I don't know if I
wrote down Gibbs' name.
He was the great
physicist at Yale, well,
a hundred years ago or
more, and did this key idea
that appears all the time,
that any time you have a step
function then the Fourier
series, it does its best,
I if I take a thousand
term, it'll do its best
but it will overshoot by
an amount that Gibbs found,
and then it will
get really close
and then it will overshoot
again and then, symmetrically.
Or anti-symmetrically,
I should say.
So that's the Gibbs phenomenon
of great importance.
I write this one out
because first it's
an important one to remember.
Second it'll give
us a good example
for this important equality,
that the energy in the function
is the energy in
the coefficient.
That'll be good.
OK, actually maybe I
should do that one first
because the delta function
has got infinite energy
and we don't learn anything
from this equation.
So let me jump to the
energy in the function
and the energy in
the coefficient.
So what do I mean by energy?
Well, it's quadratic.
Right?
It's the length squared here.
It's the length squared
of the function.
So let me compute, maybe I'll
do it on this board underneath
and leave space for
the delta function.
The energy in x space
is just the integral--
It's the length squared.
The integral of
S(x) squared. dx.
It's just what you would expect.
We have a function,
not a vector,
so we can't sum
coefficients squared.
Instead we integrate
all the values squared.
And of course, this is a
number that we can quickly
compute for that function.
So what does it turn out to be?
Well, what is S(x)
squared for that function?
One, obviously.
The function is one here.
I'm looking at the original
S(x), not the series.
The function is one there
and minus one there.
When I squared
those, S(x) squared
is one everywhere so I'm
integrating one everywhere
from minus pi to pi.
So I get the answer 2pi.
So that's a case
where the energy
in the physical
space, the x space,
was totally easy to compute.
Now, what about energy,
what is this equality?
This really neat easy
to remember equality?
I'm just going to find it by
taking this thing squared.
What's the integral of
the right-hand side?
The two are equal, so
suppose I just fire away?
I integrate the square
of that infinite series.
You're going to say, well
that's going to take a while.
But what's going to be good?
The key point, the first
point in last time's lecture,
the first point in every
discussion of Fourier series,
is orthogonality.
Sines times other sines
integrated are zero.
So a whole lot of terms will go.
So I take that
thing, I square it.
So let me let me
do that one here.
The interval from
minus pi to pi.
May I take out the
(4/pi) squared?
Just so it's not confusing.
Now, this is the sin(x)/1,
sin(3x)/3, sin(kx)/k,
and so on.
All squared. dx, and
so what do I get?
The (4/pi) squared.
And now I've got a
whole lot of terms.
But the thing is, I can do this.
Because when I square this,
I'll have a lot of terms like
sin(x)*sin(3x), and when I
integrate those I get zero.
So the only ones
that I don't get zero
are when sin(x)
integrates against itself.
And sin(3x) against itself.
So when sin(x) integrates
against itself,
that's sine squared.
Its integral is, you
remember the integral
of sine squared, which is,
its average value is 1/2.
We're over an interval-- I
think I'm going to get pi,
for sine squared.
Because sine squared-- We could
do that calculation separately.
It's just a standard integral.
The integral of
sine squared is pi.
Actually, yeah it
just uses the fact
that sine squared x is the same
as whatever it is the same as.
Is it 1-cos(2x) or something?
Over two.
Or plus, who cares?
Because the integral of
whichever, plus or minus,
let me, well I suppose
for history's sake
we should get it right.
Which is it?
Is it a minus, so
it looks OK now?
OK, alright, if it's
wrong I didn't say.
OK, but I'm going to integrate.
So the integral of
the cosine is zero,
and the integral of the 1/2
is the part I'm talking about.
That 1/2 is there all the
way from minus pi to pi.
So I get a pi.
From all these sines.
And now, what are all the terms?
Well, one over one squared,
that just had a coefficient one,
but what's the next guy?
You remember I'm squaring
it, I'm integrating.
But I have a 1/3 squared.
And 1/5 squared.
And so on.
And here's a great point.
These two are equal.
I've got the same function,
expressed in x space,
and here it's expressed in
sine space, you could say.
In harmonic space.
OK, so that's equal.
And that's going to be
the fact in general.
In general, that
the integral of S(x)
squared, so the general fact
will be the integral of-- Well,
I'll write it down below.
But let's just see what
we got for numbers here.
So I had pi on both sides.
And so if I lift that over
there, I get something
like-- what do I have?
Pi squared over 16, maybe I
have pi squared over eight.
You just get a
remarkable formula.
Putting that up there would
be pi squared over 16,
and the two makes it an eight.
And here I have the sum of
1/1 squared plus 1/3 squared
plus 1/5 squared.
So, that's an infinite
sum that I would not
have known how to do
except it appears here.
The sum of one over
all those squares.
If I picked another
example, I could
get the sum-- Oh, this was
all the odd numbers squared.
If I picked a
different function,
I could have got one that
also had the sin(2x)/2
and the sin(4x)/4.
So this would have been
the sum of all the squares.
Do you happen to know
what that comes out to be?
I mean, here's a
way to compute pi.
We have a formula for pi.
And we'd have another formula
that involved all the sums.
Maybe I have room
for it up here.
This would be the sum
of 1/n squared, right?
This here I have
only the odd ones.
And I get pi squared over eight.
Do you happen to know what
I get for all of them?
So I'm also including
1/2 squared,
there's a quarter also in here.
And also a 16th.
And also a 36th, in this one.
And the answer happens to
be pi squared over six.
Pi squared over six.
The important point about
this energy equality
is not being able to get a
few very remarkable formulas
for pi.
There's another remarkable
formula in the homework.
This is a little famous.
Do you know what this is?
This is the famous
Riemann zeta function.
The sum of 1/n^x is
the zeta function at x.
Here's the zeta function at two.
So if I could draws a zeta.
Maybe?
There's a Greek guy in
this class who could
do it properly, but anyway.
I'll chicken out.
Zeta of, at the
value two, zeta(2).
So we know zeta(2),
we know zeta(4).
I don't think we
know zeta(3), I think
it's not a special number
like pi squared over six.
So the zeta function, the
sum of 1 over n to this thing
is, actually that's the
subject of a problem
that Riemann did not solve.
There's a problem
Riemann did not solve,
and nobody has succeeded to
find it, to solve it since.
There's a million-dollar
prize for its solution.
My neighbors think I
should be working on this,
but I know better.
It's going to be solved one
day, but it's pretty difficult.
And that is to know where this
zeta function, where it's zero.
Of course, it isn't zero at two.
Because it's pi
squared over six.
And actually the conjecture
is that it's zero,
all the zeroes are at
points, complex numbers
with real part 1/2.
So they're on this famous
line, the imaginary line
with real part 1/2.
And that's the most important
problem in pure mathematics.
So here we go.
We got a formula for pi out
of this energy identity.
And I'll write it again,
once I have the complex form.
OK, but you see
where it comes from.
It just comes from
orthogonality.
The fact that we could
integrate that square
is what made it all work.
OK, let's do the delta function.
So that's an even
function, the delta, right?
Now I'm looking at
the delta function.
Minus pi to pi.
It has the spike at
zero and it's certainly
even so we expect cosines.
And what are the coefficients?
So it's just an
important one to know.
Very important example.
So what's a_0?
In general, the coefficient
a_0 in the Fourier series
is the-- If I have a
function, delta(x), S(x),
whatever my function, the a_0
coefficient is the average.
a for average, a_0
is the average value.
So this is 1/(2pi) the
integral from minus pi to pi
of my function.
Where did that come from?
I just integrated.
I just multiplied
both sides by one.
Or by 1/(2pi), and integrated.
And those terms disappeared,
and I was left with a_0,
and what's the answer?
Everybody knows that integral.
The integral of the
delta function is one,
so I just get 1/(2pi).
So 1/(2pi).
OK, now ready for a_1.
How much of cos(x) do I have?
Can I just change this
formula to give me a_1
and you can tell
me what it gives?
Well let me do it here.
Here's a_1.
What's the formula for a_1?
It's just like b_1,
like the sine formulas.
You have to remember
you're only dividing by pi.
Because that average
value was 1/2, as we saw.
And then you have the integral
of whatever your function is.
delta(x) in this case.
Times the cos(1x).
If we're looking for a_1 we've
multiplied both sides by cos(x)
and integrated.
And what answer do we get?
For a_1?
What's the integral of
delta(x) times cos(x)?
dx, so I should put in a dx.
And the answer is?
One, also one.
The delta function, this
spike, picks out the value
of this function at the spike.
Because of course
it doesn't matter
what that function is
away from the spike,
because the other
factor, delta, is zero.
Everything is at that
spike, all the action,
and this happens to
be one at the spike.
So I get a 1/pi.
And actually, the same
formula for all these guys.
This will be the same with
cos(x) changed to cos(2x).
And what will be the answer now?
Again, one.
Right?
It's the value of this integral.
The formula for
a_2 would have come
by multiplying both sides
by cos(2x), integrating.
And the integral of cos
squared would give me the pi,
and I'm dividing by
the pi, and I just
need that integral
and it's easy.
It's also 1/pi.
So all these are 1/pi.
Let me just put in the formula.
1/(2pi), and all the
rest are 1/pi. cos(3x).
All the cosines are there.
All in the same amount.
And the constant term
is slightly different.
OK, that's the formal Fourier
series for the delta function.
Formal meaning you
can use it to compute,
of course some things will
fail, like what's the energy?
If I integrate, if
I try to do energy
in x space of the delta
function, or energy in k space,
what answer would I get?
Right, the integral of
delta squared, its energy,
is infinite, right?
The integral of delta, if
I have delta times delta
then I'm really
in trouble, right?
Because this delta says,
if I can speak informally,
that delta says take the
value of this function
at zero, but of course
that's infinite,
so that would be infinite.
That would be the
energy in x space.
What about the
energy in k space?
Well, let's think, what's
the energy in k space?
I'm going to do the squares
of the coefficients,
you remember that's
what I had down here?
And I'll have it
again in a moment.
It's the sum of the squares
of the coefficients, fixed up
by factors of pi.
And here, all the
coefficients are constants.
So that sum is infinite.
Again, it's the sum of
squares, of constant,
constant, constant,
constants, and that series
doesn't converge, it blows up.
So the energy is infinite.
That's OK.
The key is that formula.
OK, there's the
formula to remember.
There's the formula.
On forever.
Every frequency is in
here to the same amount.
OK, good.
That's the delta
function example.
OK, ready to go to complex?
Complex is no big deal
because we know, actually,
you can tell me the complex
series for the delta function.
I'll write it right underneath.
The complex series for
the delta function,
just turn these guys
into e^(i*theta)--
e^(i*x)'s, and e^(i*2x)'s,
and e^(-i*2x)'s.
Just term by term,
just to see it.
To see it clearly for
this great example.
So what does cos(2x)
look like in terms
of complex exponentials?
Everybody knows cos(x) is the
same as e^(ix) and e^(-ix),
right?
Divided by two, because
this is cos(x)+i*sin(x),
this is cos(x)-i*sin(x), when
I add them I get two cos(x)'s.
So I must divide by two.
Let me divide by
two all the way.
So I'm dividing
this 1/pi by two.
You'll see it's so much nicer.
So 1/(2pi) times the one,
that's our first guy.
And now I've got the next guy.
Right?
Because I need to divide by
the two to get the cosine,
and there's my two.
OK, what's the next?
What do I have next?
From this guy.
1/pi, still there.
What's cos(2x), if I
want to write it in terms
of complex exponentials?
So this guy now, I'm ready for
him, is e^(i*2x) and e^(-i*2x).
Divided by two,
and there's my two.
Do you see what's happening?
There's an example
to show you why
the complex case is so nice.
Here we had to remember a
different number for a_0.
Here it's just, so the
next one will be e^(i*3x),
and e^(-i*3x), so that the delta
function in the complex Fourier
series, all the terms have
coefficients one divided
by the 2pi.
That's a great example.
And of course we see again that
the sum of squares, oh yeah.
So let's do the complex
formula, by which I
mean I'm taking any function
F, not necessarily even, not
necessarily odd, not
necessarily real.
Any function can now
be a complex function,
because we're going to
use complex things here.
So I'll have all the
complex exponentials.
For integer k.
This k is an integer but it
can go from minus infinity
to infinity.
That's the complex form.
F(x) is a series again.
The beauty is that every
term looks the same.
The thing you have to remember
is that negative k is allowed,
as well as positive k.
You see that we
needed the negative k
to get cosines. k was minus
1 there, k was minus 2 there.
And for sines we
would also need them.
So cosines go into
it, sines go into it.
F(x) could be complex.
That's the complex series.
So maybe we could have
started with that series.
But we didn't, we
came to it here.
But what's the formula
for its coefficient?
OK, actually, so the
next half-hour now,
we have to think complex.
And that will bring
a few changes.
So watch for the changes.
You see we're almost
in the same ballpark,
but there are a couple
of things to notice.
So let me write down
that series again.
Minus infinity to infinity
of some coefficient e^(ikx).
Now, what is c_k?
What is the formula for c_k?
As soon as we answer
that question,
you'll see the new
aspect for complex.
How do I find coefficients?
I multiply by
something, I integrate,
and I use orthogonality.
Same idea, just
repeat after repeat.
The question is, what
do I multiply by?
If I wanted to
know c_3, suppose I
want to know a formula
for c_3, the coefficient.
What am I going to
multiply by that's
going to give me the
orthogonality I need,
that all the other integrals
are going to disappear,
that's the key?
I want to multiply by something
so that when I integrate,
all the other integrals
are going to disappear.
And let's just do it.
Here, suppose I have e^(i5x).
And I'm looking for c_3.
So I'll look at e^(i3x).
So watch.
This is the small
point we have to make.
So I'm looking for e^(i3x).
So I'm going to
multiply by something,
and I'm going to integrate.
And what would be the
good thing to multiply by?
Well, you would say, if you
were just a real person,
you would say multiply
by e^(i3x), integrate.
And hope for getting zero.
You won't get zero.
If I multiply e^(i3x)--
I'm sorry, you might say--
What am I doing here?
I'm trying to check
orthogonality.
Let me instead of three use kx.
So that's a typical complex one.
It's any one of these guys.
And I want to see
what's orthogonality.
That's what I'm asking.
Everything hinged
on orthogonality.
We've got to have
orthogonality here.
But let me show you what it is.
The thing you multiply by to get
the c_3 is not e^(i3x), it is?
e^(-i3x).
You take the conjugate.
You change i to minus
i in the complex case.
So if I take e^(ikx)
times e^(-ilx),
and notice that minus,
I claim that I get zero.
Except if k is l.
And when k is l, I
probably get 2pi.
If k is l.
I get zero if k is not l.
That's the beautiful
orthogonality.
I'm not too worried about the
2pi, I'll figure that out.
So what I'm saying is, when
you're taking inner products,
dot products, and you've
got complex stuff,
one of the factors takes
a complex conjugate.
Change i to minus i.
Do you see that we've got a
completely easy integral now?
What is the integral
of this guy?
How do I see that
I really get zero?
So this is the first time I'm
actually doing an integration
and seeing orthogonality.
Anybody likes
integrating these things,
because they're so
simple to integrate.
Before I plug in
the limits, what's
the integral of this guy?
How do I rewrite that
to integrate it easily?
I put the two
exponents together.
This is the same as
e^(i(k-l)x), right?
The exponentials
follow that rule.
If I multiply exponentials,
I combine the exponents.
And now I'm ready to integrate.
And so what is the
integral of e^(i(k-l))x?
When I integrate e
to the something x,
I get that same thing again
divided by the something.
So now I've integrated, and
now I just want to go from zero
to 2pi, plug in the
limits from x=0 to x=2pi.
This is what the integral
is asking me for.
So I'm actually doing
the integral here.
I put these together
into that, I integrated,
which just brought
this term down below,
because the derivative
will bring that term above.
Oh, they weren't
meant to change.
Actually, it's wrong but right.
To change those
integration limits.
I mean, any 2pi would
work, but thank you.
You're totally right, I should
have done minus pi to pi.
Why do we get zero?
That's the whole point.
Here we actually
did the integral,
and we can just plug
in x=pi and x=-pi.
Or we could plug
in zero and 2pi,
or I could plug in any
guys that were 2pi apart,
any period of 2pi.
Why do we get zero?
Do you have to do the
plugging in part to see it?
You can, certainly.
But the point is, this
function is periodic.
That's a function
that has period 2pi.
So it has to be the same at
the lower and the upper limit.
That's what it's coming to.
That's a periodic function.
It's equal at these two limits.
And therefore, when
I do the subtraction
I take it at the top
limit, minus the answer
at the bottom limit,
it's the same at both.
So I get zero.
So there is the actual
check of orthogonality.
So the key point
was, orthogonality,
or inner product, for complex
functions, one of them
has to take the
complex conjugate.
Let me just do for vectors, too.
Complex vectors.
I may have mentioned it, let
me take the vector [1, i]
as an extreme example.
And suppose I wanted to find
the inner product with itself.
Which will be the
length squared.
What's the inner product of
that vector, that complex vector
[1, i], with itself?
Let me just raise
it up so we see it.
Focus on this.
Usually the length squared would
be one squared plus i squared.
No good.
Why no good?
Because it's zero.
One squared plus
i squared is zero.
We want absolute values squared.
Absolute values,
we need squares.
We need positive numbers here.
So the length of this
squared, I would-- So
let me call that vector v. I
want to take not v transpose
v, that's the thing that would
give me zero, if I did [1, i].
I have to take the
complex conjugate.
One of the two factors, and
it's just a matter of convention
which one you do, this is
the thing that gives me
the length of v squared.
And it's the same
thing for functions.
It's the integral of F(x)--
Do you want me to write it
as, it's the integral of
F(x) times its conjugate.
That gives me the
length of F squared.
And of course I can rewrite
that as the integral of F.
We have this handy notation
for F times its conjugate.
It's like re^(i*theta)
times re^(-i*theta),
the product of re^(i*theta)
times re^(-i*theta) is what?
This is the complex number,
this is its conjugate,
when I multiply, you notice
that i went to minus i
when I drop below the real axis,
I just change i to minus i.
So those cancel and
I get r squared.
The length, the
size of the number.
It's just, if you
haven't thought complex
just make this change
and you're ready to go.
Yeah just v bar transpose v, F
bar transpose F, if you like,
or F squared.
And when we make
the correct change
we still have the orthogonality.
OK?
So that's what orthogonality
is, now what's the coefficient?
So now, after all that
speech, tell me what
do I multiply both sides by?
Let me start again
and remember here.
So my F(x) is going to
be sum of c_k*e^(ikx).
And if I want to
get a coefficient,
I'm looking for a
formula for c_3.
So how do I find c_3?
Let me slow down a second.
How to find c_3?
Multiply both sides by what?
And integrate.
Minus pi to pi.
What goes there?
If I want c_3, I should
multiply both sides by, should I
multiply both sides by e^(i3x)?
Nope.
e^(-i3x).
Multiply both sides by
e^(-i3x) and integrate.
e^(-i3x) d x.
And then on the right
side I get what?
I get c_3, because that'll
be e^(-i3x) times e^(+i3x),
I'll be integrating one so
I get a 2pi, and all zeroes.
From all the other terms.
Orthogonality doing
its job again.
All these zeroes are
by orthogonality.
By exactly this
integration that we did.
If k is three and l is seven
or k is seven and l is three,
the integral gives zero.
So what's the formula then?
This is all gone, divide
by 2pi and you've got it.
There you are.
That's the coefficient.
OK.
We have to move to
complex numbers,
and now in those 20 minutes--
The only change to make
is conjugate one of them.
One of the things when
it can be complex.
So that's the complex series.
What's the energy
inequality now?
Let me do the energy equality
in x space and in k space.
If I take this, now
I'd like-- So that's
an equality of two functions.
Now I'd like to get it,
I want to do energy.
This is fantastic.
And extremely
practical and useful.
The fact that the energy is
going to come out beautifully,
too.
So what am I going
to do for energy?
I'm going to integrate
F(x) squared, dx.
That's the energy.
That's the energy in x
space, in the function.
What do I do now?
I integrate this series.
c_k*e^(ikx) squared.
Oh no, whoa.
If I put a square
there, right, I'm fired.
Right?
What do I have to do?
I will put a square
there, but I have
to straighten out something.
What do I do?
Those curvy lines,
which just meant
take the thing and square,
should be changed to?
Straight.
Just a matter of
getting straight.
Straightening this out.
OK, straight.
There we are.
OK.
Now, that means the thing
times its conjugate.
That's the thing
So what do I get?
All the terms disappear
except the perfect,
the ones that are squared.
So what do I get here?
And the ones that are
squared I'm integrating one,
so I get a 2pi.
So there's a 2pi.
This whole subject's full of
these pi's and 2pi's, it's
just part of the deal.
Now, what's left?
And now I'm looking
only at the terms where
I'm integrating something
by its conjugate,
by its own conjugate.
And then I'm getting c_k
times its own conjugate,
so I'm getting all the terms.
I'm getting no cross
terms, just the terms
that come from that
times it's own conjugate.
Which is c_k squared.
That's the energy
in the coefficients.
That's the energy in k
space, and of course that sum
goes minus infinity to infinity.
I've got them all.
That's the energy in k space,
here's the energy in x space.
You can expect that
this orthogonality
is going to give you
something nice for the energy.
For the integral of the square.
Alright, so you saw that.
And let's see.
So we saw it for, we
actually got a good number
for the square wave.
We got infinity for
the delta function.
I've put on here
as a last topic,
to just give the word function.
Part of what this course is
doing is to speak the language,
teach the language
of applied math.
So that when you see
something, you see this,
you recognize hey I've
seen that word before.
So I want to know, what's
the right space of functions?
This is my measure for the
length squared of a function.
My square wave is great.
It's length squared
was whatever it was,
pi squared over something.
And that's its length squared.
The delta function
gave infinity.
So it's not going to be allowed
into the function space.
It's a vector of
infinite length.
Like the vector 1,
1, 1, 1, 1 forever.
Too long.
Pythagoras fails, because we sum
the squares, we get infinite.
So what functions, what vectors
should we allow in our space?
So we're going to
have a space that's
going to be infinite-dimensional
because our coefficients,
we've got infinitely
many coefficients.
Our functions have
infinitely many values.
So we've moved up from
n-dimensional space
to infinite-dimensional space.
And everybody calls it after
the guy who, Hilbert space.
So I don't know if you've seen
that word before, that name
before, Hilbert space.
It's the space of functions
with finite energy.
Finite length.
So this function is in it, the
delta function is not in it.
And the point is that this
space of functions, we've
got-- These guys
are a great basis
for the space of functions.
The sines and cosines
are another basis
for this space of functions.
We just have a whole
lot of functions,
and all the facts of
n-dimensional space.
So what are important facts
about n-dimensional space?
One that comes to mind that
involves length is the-- A
key fact about length
is, length and angle,
I could say
actually-- Many people
would say this is the
most important inequality
in mathematics.
That the dot product
of two vectors,
it's called the
Schwarz inequality.
Several people found
it independently,
Schwarz is the single
name most often used.
What do you know about the
dot product of two vectors?
Somehow it tells you the
angle between them, right?
Somehow the dot
product of two vectors
is, if I divide by the
length of the vectors,
so the dot product of vectors
divided by the length,
do you know what
this is, in geometry?
It's a cosine.
It's the cosine of the
angle between them.
And cosines are never
larger than one.
So this quantity here is
never larger than one;
in other words,
this is never larger
than the length of one
vector times the length
of the other vector.
I could do an example.
Let v be [1, 3].
And let w be [1, 6].
I don't know how this
is going to work.
What's the dot product
of those two vectors?
Oh, it's 19.
Sorry about that.
Let's change this, I'd
like a nice number here.
What do you suggest?
Make it five somewhere?
Five wouldn't be bad.
It wouldn't be too
good either, but.
Ah, OK.
What's the dot product of those?
16.
And now what am I
claiming, that that's
length less than the length
of this vector, which is what?
What's the length of [1, 3]?
Square root of ten.
It's good to do these small
ones, just to remember.
The length of that
vector is the sum
of the square root of
the sum of the squares.
Square root of ten.
And the length of this guy?
Is the square root of 26.
And so I hope, and
Schwarz hopes, that 16
is less than that square root.
Can we check it?
Let's square both sides,
that would make it easier.
So the right-hand side when
I square both sides will be?
260.
When I square both sides,
and what's the square of 16?
256.
That was close.
But, it worked.
I'll admit to you--
Oops not equal.
Ah.
Less or equal,
Schwarz would say.
And it's actually less than
because these vectors are not
in the same direction.
If they were exactly
in the same direction,
or opposite directions,
the cosine would be one
and we would have equal.
But since the angle, you see the
angle between those two vectors
is a pretty small angle.
The cosine is quite near one.
But it's not exactly one.
So I'm glad somebody
knew 16 squared.
Does anybody know 99 squared?
The reason I ask
that is, or 999.
I'll make it sound harder.
The hope, when I was
about 11 or something,
I was I was always
hoping somebody
would ask me 999 squared.
Because I was all
ready with the answer.
Nobody ever asked.
Anyway.
But you've asked, I think.
So 998,001.
And now I I've finally got a
chance to show that I know it.
OK, have a great
weekend and see you.